hey guys welcome to the first mass
nintendo bandit video of 2021.
for this video
hey marina
excitement
b
why are you looking at me that way did
something weird happen
i'm sure it was just nothing let's look
at the 20 meanest comments from 2020.
you look like an idiot talking to
yourself la mao
i mean i don't think i do do i no i
don't think i do either
have you played the freaking champions
ballad the shrine was built for the
fifth
devin beast do you are have stupid
and then he uh replied to his own
comment sorry i didn't watch the video
it's okay buddy i forgive you although i
probably would have deleted my first
comment instead of
responding to it and leaving it on there
you know once i figured that i was just
completely wrong about the whole thing
but i am glad that you have a conscience
just a little food for thought for the
future why in the hell is this stupid
monster
i mean how gave this idea you mean who
gave me this idea might sound like a
simple question but that answer is super
complex
you see i was playing breath of the wild
one day
and i thought of it
yeah three minutes and 20 seconds of
stupid crap before they even get to what
the video is about
please cut this down
i am truly sorry
for the fact that you had to sit through
over three minutes
minutes of introducing
another zone tuber and an ad
[Music]
before getting to your free video
[Music]
what does this world come to
[Music]
your names are stupid and unnecessary
your concept of mountain formation is
idiotic
you're right man my names are stupid and
unnecessary thank you so much for
bringing it to my attention
mr uh terror toaster
[Music]
the ape died no
i help i'm being murderer you are
useless
hey you make cake stupid idiot
life is cool the police man is corrupt
you are stupid i know
i hate that i actually like this theory
oh thank you
that was so sweet i hate you for what
you did to pay up
hey now i'm sorry papaya failed on her
one job
plus that entire video was uh you know
a joke stop giving these youtuber
apostrophe as your money you
morons if you want to give money to
someone then give money to people who
actually deserve it
needs it and could use it like homeless
people or to charities that are actually
helping people or helping to save our
planet or trying to find cures for
disease and viruses like the current one
instead of giving your money to these
darn youtuber apostles yes who don't
give a crap about you
and are only using you to make money
understand that these youtuber
apostrophes
are only in it to make money that's why
they become youtuber apostrophe s
and make you space tube videos for to
make money
they don't make youtube videos because
they like making content
they do it to make money you are
meaningless to them
all you are to them is just a tool for
them to make money from you
and off of you so instead of giving
money
to people or charities that are actually
helping people and saving lives
you idiot apostle ps are giving your
money to these darn youtuber apostrophe
s
lol freaking idiot apostrophe s
so let's all just take a moment take a
moment
to respect the epic meltdown
that we just witnessed and allow me to
catch a breath
so my first reaction to this is to be
upset because he's not just insulting me
right he's insulting my viewers and my
supporters
no no no you don't do that you are mr
bandit's backless
but secondly i do kind of see what he's
saying i mean
in the grand scheme of things yes there
are charities there are homeless people
there are
hungry people that need money and if
there were like a priority list
of who you should and should not donate
you know your money to
yeah these cherries and stuff should be
towards the top of the list you know it
appeals to the good nature of humanity
youtubers would probably be somewhere in
the mid to lower section
all things considered but he also says
that youtubers
do not make youtube content because they
like the content they do it to make
money
this is just purely ignorant i don't
think he even knows that
every single youtuber has to make
content
for free without any return for a long
time sometimes
upwards of a year in my case i had to do
it for
three years before i was monetized on
youtube
so how can it not be a passion project
plus people can donate to whoever they
want to donate to
their money is their prerogative so this
comment is like 10
like all right i can see where you're
getting from but 90 just ignorant and
rude
okay we've gone through 20 of the
meanest comments on my channel from
2020. i hope you've enjoyed my reactions
to them
but i figured we would read a good
comment before ending the video
and i chose uh one comment in particular
that is the greatest comment i've ever
received
on any video for the entirety of my
youtube career i just want to tell you
you're the only zelda theorist i can
actually watch
you're amazing you're the only one who
sounds genuine not like they're reading
directly off a script
and you don't patronize your viewers by
acting like we don't know common
theories like most z
tubers i love your style of humor and
you cover topics that others youtubers
wouldn't even think of
keep doing what you do so let me get the
disclaimer out of the way i disagree
with the
portion of this comment that says that i
am better than others youtubers
i disagree i am not my favorite z tuber
every time i watch a hyrulegamer upload
or
a celtic upload or a monster or a
nintendo black crisis
commonwealth realm uh hmk every time i
watch one of their videos i am so
inspired
because these people are so driven and i
just want to be
like them so i wouldn't say i'm the best
one by far
i'm just trying to make my way but
that's the other reason why i actually
like this comment so much because this
is the heart and soul of what i try to
do i try to be unique
i try to be genuine i try to be someone
that you enjoy
watching because you enjoy me as much as
my content
so for me especially starting out it was
a big struggle i'm like
finding my niche and finding like what
makes me
and my videos special why would somebody
click on my video instead of somebody
else's it's actually one of the biggest
things on my mind and one of the big
reasons why i made this video
so anyway this person if you're watching
right now
you have no idea what this comment meant
to me and means to me i read this like
at least twice a day just to keep myself
going and keep myself motivated because
this
is why i do what i do thank you
so much and for everybody watching it
doesn't have to be a comment
every time that you just watch a video
or click the like button or
subscribe that is everything to me and
it's one of the reasons why we have been
growing so
fast and i owe all of it to you i mean
you guys even got me one of these things
how cool is that and you know what
before we kick off into the rest of 2021
let's finish this video with one more
comment i'll find a nice one
okay here we go me clicking on this
video i am pretty sure i don't like
where this is going
me after watching this video i hate it